v aus 42 wird methan auf einem
treibhausgas wird ein gas was man dann
wieder thermisch verwerten kann
das gab's kohlenstoffdioxid ist ja ein
großer faktor wenn es um die erwärmung
der erde geht genauso wie herr methan
aber forscher suchen nach möglichkeiten
42 umzuwandeln und mit hilfe von lich
ist das jetzt auf eine einfache art
gelungen und methan kann man ja
anderweitig nutzen also jetzt bei king
kong science fiction herzlich willkommen
eigentliches methan ja auch ein
hochwirksames treibhausgase kommt nur in
spuren in der atmosphäre vor aber hat
eine erhebliche wirkung auf die
erderwärmung aber was wäre wenn man co2
darf nur 1 abgab ist zu methan wann
könnte das wäre sensationell
dann könnte das methan durch verbrennung
zur energieerzeugung genutzt werden und
das entstandene co2 wieder in methan
umgewandelt werden und so weiter ein
klimaneutraler kreislauf wäre entstanden
und es scheint möglich forscher von der
duke university in north carolina in den
usa haben es geschafft den prozess der
umwandlung von schädlichen co2 zu wasser
und methan zu vereinfachen
dieser vorgang auch sabatier prozess
genannt war bisher allerdings sehr
energieintensiv das ergebnis ist jedoch
recht anstreben der kohlenstoff und
wasserstoff werden in einer chemischen
reaktion zu wasser und methan gewandelt
das methan lässt sich dann als
energieträger weiter verwenden oder kann
in der industrie eingesetzt werden die
für diesen prozess erforderlichen hohen
temperaturen konnten die forscher nun
ersetzen durch licht zuerst stellten die
wissenschaftler nano-partikel her
dafür verwendeten wie rhodium die
bestrahlten die romano partikel mit
ultravioletten licht aus einer led lampe
das durchströmende co2 wurde so in
methan umgewandelt sie verglichen das
neue verfahren das bei raumtemperatur
durchgeführt werden kann
mit dem herkömmlichen verfahren bei
hohen temperaturen dabei konnten die
wissenschaftler feststellen dass wir den
prozess der umwandlung sogar noch
optimieren kommt denn bei rund 300 grad
celsius entsteht neben den gewünschten
produkten außerdem noch kohlenmonoxid
jetzt bei raumtemperatur lag die
umwandlungsrate bei fast 100 prozent in
meta der effekt wird dabei genutzt
worden
immonen resonanz und die kommt bei dem
rhodium nanopartikeln zum tragen
dazu der wissenschaftler händel everett
im grunde funktionieren platonische nano
partikel wie kleine antennen die
sichtbares oder ultraviolettes licht
sehr effizient absorbieren und zum
beispiel starke elektrische felder
erzeugen können
zitat ende die energie für den prozess
kommt also aus der lichtquelle und nicht
durch die hitze und ist dabei sogar noch
effizienter die forscher haben nun vor
die größe der teilchen noch zu
verringern um so möglich zu machen
die reaktion auch bei sonnenlicht
durchführen zu können damit würden
tatsächlich war die fossile brennstoffe
durch sonnen nicht hergestellt werden
sensationell und gewinnt hier ein abo
aufs auge drücken wird und vergesst
nicht mir einen auch noch auf die glocke
zu geben um auch gerne mal ein video von
6 16 meter passen darunter hier geht es
zu einem weiteren video zum thema
klimawandel und was meint ihr
wenn sie das problem mit dem co2
überschuss bald los ist die wissenschaft
kreativ genug diskutiert es in den
kommentaren und ansonsten wird dann
bleibt dran